this was truly extraordinary hi I'm
Mickey and I try new things today I made
folded kimbap inspired by the kdrama
extraordinary attorney Wu for the first
time it was actually quite easy to make
I just cook everything in this cute
little tamagoyaki pan this was my first
attempt making it I put rice lunch and
meat egg and kimchi in each compartment
and folded it I also cover it completely
with Saran Wrap and sliced it and it
looks magnificent for the second version
I actually placed the rice in two of the
squares because the kimchi by itself was
too messy I also used beef slices for
this version if you enjoyed this video
follow BuzzFeed shopping for more but
let me just tell you